hey everybody Alexa right here on the
GameSpot war room stage I am here with
chatham insomniac games hey there hey
and we're gonna take a look at the brand
new bracket and Clank which is a game
based on a movie based on a game that's
right that's what we say about it and
it's actually totally true
cool so this is the this is a level that
we've seen previously we did a video
last week I got a chance to chat with
you guys now can you just talk a little
bit more about the design philosophy
behind that brief remaking reimagining
yeah yeah I mean yeah some of those work
I mean when we started this game we we
knew we never wanted to make it just
like a remaster or an oppressor Nam
this was all about making a new game
that tied in to the upcoming feature
film so we had this this great
opportunity to make a game and film that
were in sync in terms of telling like a
deeper look at ratchet and clanks origin
story so and both of them are based on
elements of the PlayStation 2 original
but you know the game is just a ton of
new stuff that's all designed to work
well with the feature film but also give
kind of a unique a different perspective
on the origin of so I noticed there are
a couple weapons in this game that we're
not in the first game yes my favorite
being the groovey Tron which I hope we
have an opportunity to use very soon
yeah yeah the groove of Tron was you
know kind of a weapon that we came to
during the Future series and it's it's a
fan favorite I mean we're in the mindset
now that a Ratchet and Clank game ought
to have a groove of Tron because you
ought to be able to see every enemy
dance I think yeah there we go the
Returns come in now so yeah like we were
able to really take a look at our
arsenal over the years and kind of pick
some of the best stuff and and also
combine them with some brand new weapons
like the pixel Iser that we're using
right there what's that from that's from
the film right that's a brand-new one
for the game and it turns enemies into
explosive 8-bit pixels that then you
know fly off into all directions with
physics so yeah we feel like we got the
awesome power of a PlayStation 4 and
that immediately did our retro thing
with it just because we couldn't help
ourselves how how different has it been
developing this game for PlayStation 4
than it has her previous console
generations I know everyone that I talk
to you is making ups for game always
talks about its power what is that what
does that mean well I mean to us it
means we can do things we always wanted
to like
just an insane draw distance with the
city this is a Lehrer City which we call
metropolis a lot in other games and it
has always been about all of this
density of traffic and extremely long
fuse and in this game we've been able to
realize it it's kind of a real space a
lot more than we ever could before also
we can do things with shaders that are
brand new for us I mean ratchet and
clanks always been about like shiny
surfaces yeah now those services are
like really reflective and really
reacting to the Sun and light accurately
and you've got the voice actor for
ratchet is James Arnold Taylor correct
yes James Arnold Taylor was not in the
first game but he's in this one so it's
kind of like ratchet having the the
right character based on what we've
learned over the years for his origin
story awesome so this is I'm noticing
there's a lot of this is this it to me
it feels it feels like the original game
but it's not so how did you what was the
biggest challenge in reimagining I keep
wanting the same every reboot can we
call it a reboot I mean I guess that's
an OK way to think of it it is
definitely you know getting back to the
roots of Ratchet and Clank in a lot of
ways but you know if you play the first
game now on the PlayStation 2 the
controls are very different like it was
kind of figuring out third-person
shooter controls in a lot of ways like
this was sort of a dawn of time as far
as that's concerned in a lot of ways but
over the years we've really modernized
the control scheme so now we have
strafing and we have much better ease in
and out on the reticle like all these
things that you sort of expect from
playability in a modern shooter or
things that we've added to the the games
over the years so we were able to bring
all of that like kind of everything that
we've learned over 10 ratchet games and
put it back into this one and kind of
say like here's the first look at
Ratchet and Clank again with now all of
the best stuff that we've learned over
the years so it's the ultimate ratchet
experience I think that's a good way to
think of it definitely awesome now this
you were telling me this is an area from
the first game but there's something
very different that's right this is
planet gas bar and if you see the
section that we're playing through right
now this is real estate that will look
familiar to players of the original game
like the enemies that were fighting the
play paths they're dancing to the to the
group whole thing I think it's so cute
everything in it
nice nice dancing hoppers now you have
to die explosively but yeah so like
you'll see that parts of this first
section are familiar alone you know the
turret was here in the first game like a
lot of this real estate has been carried
over but at the same time we've got like
a brand new area of the game that is
based on exploration planets that we
started using like a ps3 era ratchet
destructions and this is all like brand
new stuff so James is gonna jump on the
grind rail now and this is into a brand
new section at the level that wasn't in
the original game it's been completely
oh man designed for what we can do now
you know this grind rail wasn't a part
of the original game so it's it's all of
this you know brand new stuff that's
kind of built to take advantage of like
you know we want to kind of show more
detail about what's going on
on all the planets the film handles a
lot of things with montage or with sort
of like implied action and we're able to
kind of dig in and really show like all
the details what's really happening so
you can fill in the gaps and kind of get
the full story so it's sort of like so
it's not film a game based on film based
on a game so it's sort of it's it's the
film and you're sort of taking taking
parts of it and just sort of expanding
it so this is the full experience that's
a good way to think of it it's kind of
like two different points of view for
the same big story so they each give you
something a little different you know
the film goes into a lot of detail with
characters and emotional art and the
game is it's got that but it's also
getting into detail with the action on
here we're talking to a large scientist
who's telling you you can go find brains
from epatha poses that are like all over
this planet's surface that's going to
open up a lot more of the level if you
can manage to complete his quest oh wow
I just noticed Clank on his back super
cute just hanging out happy yeah he's
paying attention he'll you know he'll
put his two cents in occasionally that
he's he's always there and ratcheting oh
my gosh then we have quite gameplay in
this game a lot as well oh yeah which
wasn't in the first such a detailed way
like lots of different puzzles space
is a whole lot of quake action going on
how do you approach when you're
designing puzzles for for ratchet and
then when you're designing a puzzle for
Clank what is the what is the major
major differences and challenges for you
in terms of creating to sort of the two
different experiences so you know
ratchets all about using the weapons and
it's all about fast-paced action whereas
Clank is a lot more cerebral so it's
like well you know how can we make a
really good puzzle that's really gonna
like test your brain tell like trying to
go back and forth fluidly between those
two different sides of the coin
visceral action to you know more
cerebral puzzles I love that pixel idea
it's so good no no this this area is all
this is like a real open-world gameplay
section now so James is gonna go through
and solve challenges and kind of collect
brains as he goes but you know the more
that he collects he can go back to the
blarg scientist and more and more of the
are there a lot of areas like this sort
of scattered throughout the world yeah
there are a lot of new ones so we have
several planets that are brand new that
were never featured in the first game
but we also have planets that are are
from the first game that we revisit and
at all of those there are revised
gameplay setups that take advantage of
the modern controls they're also brand
new gameplay segments all over the state
as well I really get in and like like in
the first game this was one of the
smallest planets and we always had the
ideas for it that we couldn't realize
but in this one we've been able to go
back and really do so you guys have put
a it sounds like a lot of work into this
new game yeah that's a fair thing to say
how long have how long have you been
working on it well we were working on it
for a bit and we started at the same
time the film started okay which is you
know another main thing to know like
these two things have been really in
sync kind of co-developed and brought up
together such that we can share models
and set pieces and you know writing
which is an unusual situation like that
almost never happens but it's been this
real thing that we got to do for this
one so it's not a movie tie-in game it's
a movie
in game you can say that for sure it's
it's it's a complementary work to the
film the two of them are kind of
designed to go together oh no and now
we're using the jetpack so this is a
gadget that we brought into later games
like into the Nexus and now that now
that we've earned it and find a gas bar
like we can get way way up high and kind
of go anywhere in the level nice even
more space you also have you added the
weapon upgrade system the Nexus yep
that's correct so weapons upgrades as
weapons upgrade as you use them they get
better and better but also you can spend
your rare attain 'i'm however you want
so if you want to focus on damage or if
you want to focus on range any of those
things you can make your weapon arsenal
your own that's so cool
yeah that's something that you know we
didn't get a chance to do in the first
game we came about it later and ratchet
titles again it's just bringing all of
our best stuff back to this one so what
is your what is your favorite thing
about the new ratchet light I I mean I
guess I'm gonna have to say that just
the way we were able to handle all of
the visuals the way we'd always wanted
to you know we have certain looks in our
heads we've always wanted to make the
game look like a CG film in every way
and I feel like for the first time we've
been able to make things
I'm truly shiny and resolved the full
range of color and value that we've
always I love that I love that pixel
Iser so much I think it might be my
favorite my favorite new thing yeah we
like the way it sounds
that is great like 8-bit sound effect
that goes along with it I don't know it
brings back nostalgia while you're also
so this is a this is what what we're on
right now is a sidequest
that's right Frank yeah can we expect
many of those there are a lot of them
yeah yeah you know things that aren't
required at all that are just branching
paths that'll you know though that's
what you can do they'll improve your
weapons and your own XP by awesome and
this is is this playable this week is
playable on the show floor we've got two
different locations to show we've got a
gyro city which is also called
metropolis and we've also got
g34 which has a boss battle with the
Snuggle beast I heard that you could
also make the bosses dance that's right
like you could make every you can make
everybody dance in this game pretty much
if there's a thing we make it dance and
we have to do it that way our animators
love to make dance animations more than
anything it would be like me dancing I
can already see the the YouTube videos
of Just Dance montages yep see them
that's what we want cool is this the was
this the last one we need to get the
brain yeah I think he's gonna be able to
oh he's got he's got 11 more to pick up
like there there are a ton like it just
it goes wow yeah these were super
involved it's it's a big level this is
awesome so how about how big would you
say would you say if you could describe
the entire the entire world available to
available to players in this game for
the whole game I mean it's a full sized
Ratchet and Clank game so we're talking
about 12 plus hours we're talking about
a whole lot of site things and a lot of
replay you know branching paths and all
that stuff that's awesome well this is
the new Ratchet and Clank a game based
on a movie based on a game that's it
coming in spring 2016 alongside the film
that's it yeah awesome
thank you so much for stopping by and
showing us this tune in to GameSpot calm
for news throughout the week thank you
everybody
thanks